Oscar fun Deventer loves brainteasers he
designs all kinds of tricky puzzles
including this one made us wished friend
he wanted to propose to his girlfriend
Mindy and what he asked me is to design
for him a Rubik's Cube that when it's
solved it can be opened and guess what's
there a ring and then of course he asked
will you marry me and she said yes she
have to solve the puzzle first it's just
one of more than 500 puzzles that Van
Deventer has created since 1978 the
Dutchman is actually a scientist
federal research institute he began
licking up new prisons at an early age
it started when I was 12 and there was
this book suppose of the world and they
showed how to make puzzles
yeah from their own book and then I
started designing myself Jesus for him
[Music]
he does the pieces assembles them
himself the stickers requires dexterity
and patience but it's a labor of love
for years he didn't learn a sin from his
inventions for the first 20 or 25 years
that I've been working on puzzles I've
not sold a single puzzle so it's very
hard but all that changed in 2008 thanks
to the Internet hi I'm Oscar from Dave
hunter and welcome to my youtube channel
on Oscar puzzle he presents a new
prototype each week some of his videos
have garnered up to three million views
this is the dumbbells cube again puzzle
for intellectual weightlifters he
produces the videos in the backyard of
his home in the Dutch town of lighten up
yo che his wife of 30 years is a big
help they've been making the videos
together since 2008 my Demeter's youtube
career began almost by chance and this
is the bony cube
the reason for me to start the YouTube
channel was that I wanted to show a
puzzle of mine to producer in Japan so
but I didn't want to sent in the
prototype because that takes weeks for
the parcel to arrive and YouTube was
quite new in well I think 2008 or so so
I just made the video and I sent a link
to the producer prototypes I found their
way to games manufacturers and garniture
production like Oscars treasure chests
the kewpie designed for his friend to
2011 fund editor earned a Guinness world
record for his most complex project to
date a Rubik's tile cube comprised on
1539 parts you can solve it but it takes
quite a while as youtuber red Cavey
shows in this time-lapse video it took
kind of Brendan seven hours and me it'll
probably take a bit longer but I used
the screwdriver solution so I pop off
the cap and I use my screwdriver and
then everything goes to parts and then
we have to assemble everything again and
that's a lot of work oscar's debitor now
has many fans and friends around the
globe some Senjem presents fathers
commissioned them to design custom a
puzzles but the inventor has no trouble
coming up with ideas of his own I have a
whole list of ideas that I can work on
and sometimes the list gets too long and
then I throw it away and I start a new
list soon he'll also need to puzzle out
a new way of storing his inventions but
a man is a genius
as Oscar vandevander is sure to come up
with something
you
[Music]